No animals can communicate through a medium,...
...which includes all the features of human language,...
...but all humans can.
Human activity is complex and varied,...
...and so is the study of language and linguistics.
I shall now return to the different branches of linguistics,...
....which you will encounter in this faculty.
These range from morphology and syntax to the study of areas...
...such as psycholinguistics and sociolinguistics.
These areas may seem unfamiliar to you now,...
...but if you use your knowledge of affixes and combining forms,...
...then you can work out the meanings of some of these branches.
For example, psycholinguistics is concerned with psychology...
...and how language affects learning.
Sociolinguistics involves society and people's attitudes...
...to standard and nonstandard forms of language.
The ology in morphology brings us back...
...to the concept of linguistics as a scientific study.
In this case, morphology refers to the study of word structure,...
...in other words, how different elements or morphemes,...
...combine to form what we call words.
Oh and the 'syn' in syntax means 'together.'
So, syntax means the way words are combined or arranged in sentences.